captain pete maverick mitchell
here we go
in three
two
one
having any
your talent is next level oh thank you
you inhabited goose on a level
that
you know i mean physically when i look
at you you don't really look alike
but the it was like haunting in a way so
how much did you sort of
channel study
anthony edwards performance was that a
huge aspect of getting into this
character i think i
i mean i remembered enough of of having
seen the film to to understand what you
know what anthony did with it and what
goose kind of what that feeling was like
and kind of the the character you know
the role that he played in it and then
with rooster
you know he he's had a totally different
life experience than you know than than
goose had and so i was trying to
you know kind of understand uh you know
and have a lot of buddies in the
military and you know their parents that
you know we're in the military and the
reason why they followed in their their
parents footsteps and what it meant for
them to kind of you know carry on that
legacy so um i mean yeah i'm so glad you
you thought that it was kind of you know
in the mix i actually went back to the
original because i couldn't remember how
old
you were in that part and he was old
enough to remember so the fact that you
do come full circle and you do sing that
song i know you play you actually play
the piano
um so you as the character do you say to
yourself i remember that i remember my
dad that was our defining moment that
was my defining moment of my dad and
that's why you're carrying it forward i
mean i i think with
you know probably how it
would have went i mean me personally i
couldn't even tell you what my first
memory so i don't really know but i but
i just know how these things go when
someone in the military uh pass away um
the guys that he works with um really
make a point to be a part of that kids
you know family for forever and so as he
would get older that's when these guys
would share you know you know some
stories with them and
and so i you know and i love that they
do that that it means a lot to them when
um
you know to make sure that they are a
part of that that
you know that family's life uh i love
hearing the story that the first time
you got on set with tom you started the
maverick chant you're like maverick
maverick and i've seen a couple
interviews you do with tom and i would
be like just so nervous and you seemed
so cool with him yeah and that chemistry
really comes off on screen can you talk
about creating that chemistry with tom
because i think initially maybe you sort
of weren't sure about taking the role
and he kind of convinced you well i was
i just i wasn't
yeah to be fair yeah i wasn't i wasn't
sure i didn't know i had never been a
part of something this that i knew was
going to be this big and i that's not
something that i take lightly i think if
you're going to be a part of something
you should really
think uh think about all aspects of it
but you know with as far as tom goes in
the camaraderie i think i just
he's just so great man he really is uh
so disarming and he
he really did not to make a pawn but you
know he took me under his wing and he
told me he said anything you need in
your life uh anything anything you ever
want to ask he's like just give me a
call and that's you know that's been
true personally and professionally he's
you know he's always been there for me
so why did you start the maverick chat
just to sort of break the idea yeah dude
i would do that all the time um because
i would carry a bluetooth speaker and so
in scenes that were if i felt like the
tension was kind of high in this i
literally would play something from the
top gun soundtrack just to
just to you know loosen it up a little
bit the dj you're the dj of the set yeah
i'm sure it got old at some point but i
i just i try and keep it loose if i can
that could have been your call sign but
you actually chose rooster i did yeah
yeah why specifically just sort of
homage uh yeah i mean we we list we
looked at hundreds if not thousands of
call signs there was an origin there was
another call sign
that was in the script that i thought i
thought you know if i can if i can beat
it if i can find something else and
you know the fact that it's in bird
family i thought that was a nice kind of
wink without being too on the nose and
so i'm glad i'm glad it fits uh
this film has so many great mantras
the my favorite and one of my favorite
moments in the film and i'm not going to
spoil it is don't i don't think just do
do you have a mantra that you live by i
don't know man i i think it's just
there's something that my parents kind
of
instilled in me at a young age is just
you know you're who you are when you
know when you put your head on your
pillow at night so all this other stuff
and
you know it's really just who you are as
a person i've always tried to
carry myself a certain way and be a
certain type of person i think there's a
certain morality that was probably
instilled in me at a young age now i
heard that you said you underestimated
what it would be like to actually go
through all the training you really
underestimated it so can you kind of
give i know people talk about oh pulling
g's and this and that and the underwater
can you give me a sense of like at least
at one moment the moment you were like
oh my gosh like this is i don't know if
i can do this kind of thing yeah i mean
there was there's a training course that
we had to pass in san diego where they
essentially blindfold you
and strap you to a chair
and then submerge you in water and then
flip you upside down and that that's i
mean just imagine that like that is a
pretty
that's a pretty unusual situation to be
in um and then there were a couple of
flying
moments where you know we're going into
a canyon going 580 knots or 480 knots
100 feet off the ground into a canyon
you know and the
the walls are like you know maybe less
than 100 feet
off each wing tip and so that was
that was pretty wild um i love that your
character doesn't sort of feel like he
has to be too tough there's a real
vulnerability to it was
was that a choice you specifically made
was it in the script was it through
conversations with tom and and you know
producers and that i think i just really
i just really felt for the kid and i
think that
uh when you really kind of start putting
all the pieces together of you know what
it
must be like for him and knowing in the
you know in the back of your head
knowing how your your father you know
passed away and how things can go wrong
up there real quick i don't care how
confident you are there needs to be that
you know there is that element of
you know
the mortality of it right because it
does happen to these these guys and
especially
i think he i think yeah there's a
certain layer of doubt in himself that
the character rooster has that some of
the other
characters don't have um 20 pounds of
muscle you put on for this is that oh
dude i was i mean yeah i usually walk
around i think like 185 i was at one
point i was like 210 pounds and i was
just
yeah so
just yeah big and yeah
tan
you have to eat so much it's like hard
like to get like to gain that much well
you just have to eat so much but you're
like tan
yeah tan you got to be tanned i'm kind
of jealous of that i spray tan it's top
gun you got to be you got to be team
oily yeah at times oily is a must for
top gun i think how did you feel about
that scene watching it back i know you
worked your butts off i think i think
you're just happy to
to
you know because that that first scene
was so iconic and i think if anything i
was just more like
i'm glad we're doing this as a film
because i think the fans will
uh will enjoy that that we did that's
one of the first things people have
asked me is there a you know is there a
volleyball scene and i heard your
friends are pissed that you're in this
movie they're so jealous that's getting
some legs to it i did say that but it is
i just think they're they're just hoping
that they're able to watch this movie
that they want to watch so bad and that
not be thrown off that uh you know that
their buddy is is in it so give us a
peek behind the curtain of the wizard of
oz when you're got the the sound speaker
going and you're pulling pranks and
you're doing all this how is tom
reacting i feel like he loves you and he
loves that you just don't care kind of
thing
yeah yeah yeah he does i mean tom
he's
you know he i don't know i mean he's got
a lot of extreme hobbies for sure but he
just loves making movies you know that's
really his number one
hobby it's his profession he just he
really loves he loves it so i'm able to
i don't know i have fun when i'm on set
i'm having a great time
what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special fellas this here's bag
man hang man whatever what the hell kind
of mission is this
[Music]
i saw your instagram can you start us
off with a press tour
well this is day two of the top gun
maverick press tour
and we don't get tired that was very
good thank you for doing that i'm going
to ask you to perform one more time can
you guys reenact your best g's face
because in the trailer we got to see all
your g's faces can you do it right here
right now you know i usually don't do
this on the second day
i'm just thinking i'm like
are we doing it at the same time okay
yeah we have two at the same time wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait i'm gonna say pulling your jeez
okay all right wait wait wait wait wait
are you gonna stay here we gotta
throttle up all right paul
geez
what's up oh come on you look at this
crap
yeah
tarzan's
okay so between the three of you who has
the best call sign i think i do oh can
you please look over here easily you're
looking at them tell me why yours is the
best
because i think it is who you are and
so i am greg tarzan davis and i play
coyote uh and coyote is the best because
i mean
do i have to explain something like that
yeah
cause it sounds like you don't remember
i play fanboy and my name is just
anyone that watches this movie is going
to relate to being a fanboy because it's
a 10 out of 10 film it is a perfect
movie it should be nominated for all the
like everything so it's just like
sit in my
yeah you're just going to visualize
yourself in my under my helmet
he's got you beat glenn
i i feel like guys i mean there have
been online polls and hangman has just
smoked all of you first off yeah but
hangman was the first that was the
original word
it's a great game
um the original wordle guys hangman was
the original wordle technically i wanted
to start calling you a wordle now oh
don't go
on call
oh no
okay i'm gonna stick with you for a
second how did you get your family in
the film was it the bar scene and where
can fans find your family in this film
yeah
i actually had you guys remember this i
probably had about 18 of my friends and
my family it was uh the second time
we're in the heart right yeah exactly
and so we did all the
casting
i got pretty much all of my friends in
flight suits uh
into this bar scene but my dad i went to
craft services and came back and my dad
was on all four monitors and i was like
oh no like that's usually a bad sign if
you're if your dad's like who's this guy
and he uh
he found himself right behind miles when
miles playing great balls of fire on the
piano which is just such a great scene
you will see
the og we call him the original glenn
right behind him and he is just uh and
he smoked it his his performance is
truly it's gripping he brought so much
energy
it was authentic too yeah it's just for
sure he had a whole arc too
back story he did a lot of character
research
um
who got you got a ride home with tom on
the last day oh so we did so but so
essentially i fin i got wrapped i landed
uh from doing my final scene landed in
the f-18 we reviewed the footage and
then tom was like you two going to la
and then we're like yeah and he's like
all right get get your bags so then from
landing the f-18 then tom piloted us
back to la uh to was it lax no no no
it's some private van
yeah one of the private ones i can't
yeah
at that point we land our cars are there
waiting we're like what the hell was
this and then just tom takes off in his
motorcycle yeah and we're like that's
the most that's the phone
that's that was my final day on top we
looked at it
i did not know that it was f-18 directly
to the pj and then he just rides away
into the sunset can i just tell you my
favorite thing that tom does it's it's
the exit his he does the maverick exit
every time i'll be talking to him and
he's like all right man have a good
night throw on the helmet take off into
the night and i'm like damn that's cool
then the p51 he'll literally all right
guys great shooting dane to take off
from the p-51 into the sunset we're
doing like a slow-mo walk like the first
time in full flight gear yeah and then
we see that there's a plane in the
distance and just as it crosses through
the sun so you see it's silhouette like
right in front of the sun and you it
actually made the photos we took he just
he just moves away over the sun just
like the guy knows his angle he knew the
length of the lens it was unbelievable
what did he teach you guys about doing
like first of all did he teach you how
to nail the one-liner because between
like i want the truth you complete me
all of that he has so many iconic
one-liners i know this is somewhat like
a film school for you guys what did he
teach you you had you had to work your
own cameras about creating a blockbuster
you know you taught us about filmmaking
all like you said about uh camera angles
about lighting about what the audience
wants uh storytelling you know so we
were able to really convey how this
message will impact the audience i think
that shows on in the movie
yeah i think uh blockbuster or not i
think
when he brings to any film he does i
think it lends itself to
what he does lends itself to any type of
movie he's making no matter the scale if
it's an indie or a blockbuster or grant
that doesn't make indies at this point
um
but i think it just it's
i've taken it with me to wendy's and
it's just a responsibility of
giving your absolute all every single
moment you can and he leads by example
from the first day we started on this
movie speaking of great one-liners like
there's a couple of great mantras in
this film like don't think what's each
of your personal mantra
in life do you have one yeah
i'll get tired because i can't get tired
i knew that i still knew that it is
right
guys you really do live by that one
you're like the only person that
actually has a mantra that says it
constantly you don't just say it to
yourself
you know you got to back it up too i
don't know if i have a mantra
have you seen me say monster to myself
in the corner have fun man i don't know
yeah
keep it keep it light have fun i don't
know
[Laughter]
okay you lot you won the last contest
but you did it i did it yeah
that was awkward
i don't think i have
okay let's talk about the oiling up the
beach scene then that's a lot easier to
talk
to talk about let's talk about male
grooming so i heard that you guys shot
it and then you all engorged on food and
then you had to reshoot the scene like
two weeks later after that we went and
we had tater tots and hot sausage or hot
dogs
hot hot dog wieners or something like
that and and
then they tell us there's a rumor that
that we have to shoot it again it's like
we just put on so much weight in like
two hours
what
yeah the the the problem is the first
the first movie nobody knew that scene
was gonna be iconic in this one we were
like there was a drama they're like all
right we knew this thing was coming we
knew the day where all everybody's there
were guys eating protein paste
it was it was bad like
you came out with the bands too oh the
resistance on the bands on the beach
yeah there were
what else was there there's some footage
out there that's monica to show you the
footage of all of us just going crazy
she's just like oh my gosh boys oh my
gosh this needs to be in an extended cut
or something yeah we also have we have
some really fun videos uh on the carrier
gym too
yes yeah we started doing video montages
of working out and it was just yeah
slow-mo did you hit the slow-mo oh wait
slow-mo oh nice
i have never worked out in fasmo
also during prep there was he was he was
preparing with his trainer and i think
it was
maybe before we met i'm not sure but it
was he had this this instagram post i
just said montages are forever
you should see glenn busting his tail
working out and they just like it
brought the severity of this and i think
that trickled down to everyone like oh
my god yeah montages are for i love that
you remember that yeah the caption was
sounding funny yeah yeah you reminded me
so much of a nice man in this film did
you sort of study is that sort of was
that the sort of the inspiration in a
way or did it just happen and then for
you you have bragging rights because
you're also in mission impossible
so i want to know about the difference
between a top gun film and mission
impossible you can go first okay yeah um
no i i tried to look valkomer is one of
my favorite actors
you cannot top val he's iconic in his
own way so you know i i think you have
to honor some of the things from the
first one and obviously um
you know there are things that the
audience wants in certain prototypes the
audience wants but i
tried to try to make it my own as much
as i could you know i wanted hangman and
iceman to exist in their own in their
own worlds
yeah oh mission mission impossible seven
uh
they're the same but they're different i
mean tom he approaches each role in each
project with the same intensity and and
the same level of stunts and everything
and same level of quality but it's it's
also different because he always tries
to outdo himself and i told him i said
when i saw top when i said yo how are
you going i'll do top gun and mcewen and
tom said that's the goal if we're not
trying to strive to do it then what are
we doing it for us okay one last one
last
doing a top gun film you know that when
you watch the trailer or a featurette
you're gonna be like oh i look so badass
in that what was your moment where
you're like oh i'm a badass that's my
moment
those he pulls that um we do not look
cool on those i think we look so cool
like we look we're going we're working
yeah i was like our bodies are
absolutely going through this there's no
girl in the world that looks at the hick
maneuver face and goes that's a cool
honestly
that's the freaky feature right i sent
like a 10 minute voicemail with y'all to
be like yo we look badass yeah
i love it
my mantra if we're going to go with the
mantra it's voice voice notes from
tarzan are the greatest coffee in the
entire world he's about as hyped as
anyone about life as i've ever see so he
checks out all the interviews and then
gives comments on them
this guy's like if anybody is watching
president yeah he says like glenn
interviews he's like oh my god check out
this moment yeah i'm like we don't need
to revisit this
i just love watching i love them when
i'm not around them i want to watch them
that's all you know what it is you're a
real wingman that's what it is you're
you're a supporter of everybody
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they going to get to teach
us
congratulations on the best movie i've
ever seen in my entire life
i swear i swear it's so good i'm sure
everybody's saying this to you um i did
this with the other trio i hope you'll
indulge me i usually don't ask people to
perform but they had a contest who can
pull the best pulling g's face like
re-enact your pulling g's face right
here right now who won over there first
uh
i feel like glenn glenn might have won
it's kind of a it's kind of a loose skin
thing can you use your hands yes you're
gonna win okay i have a lot of losers on
the count of three no that's not fair
that's not pulling yourself but you
don't know but you don't know my hair is
really good you're not like up there you
don't have to mess up the hair don't
make me it's gonna it's it's okay on the
couch
one
two
three
this is blackmail this is blackmail you
have here yeah what did you do that's a
gift that's a future gift in the making
[Laughter]
the other room we'll say that definitely
that week
that glenn was maybe the winner he was
like i'm going to step up i'm going to
do a couple on broadway by the way
between each of you who do you think has
the best call sign argue why your
character has the best call sign name
i think bob has the best call sign yeah
and he just told us why two seconds ago
yeah if you throw me in the ocean on bob
you're gonna stick with that you're
gonna you're gonna really stick with me
i will love it it's actually a part i
mean as you know part of the film you
know what does it stand for and we don't
tell you oh yeah i know it's true yeah
there is an unknown the kind of call
sign you could like make up a story
every no he's sticking with bobbin in
the ocean we're throwing him in the
ocean
that's gonna be part of this press run
everyone's gonna watch him bob do you
remember in the
original script what it actually stands
for though cause it's something kind of
really cool and and you can't even
really but you know what the word i know
whatever in the first script the world
would never know that
what is it
nope um that's a new film
it changes it changes that's true by the
day it changes by the day yes
morphing but payback in phoenix are
pretty cool too so
yeah why are yours the coolest
well i think the fun thing about our
call signs is that we
at first they were sort of given to us
which the whole thing about call signs
is like you do something embarrassing
and then they call you that for the rest
of your life um and
we had a very different experience with
it but then we sort of earned our call
signs in these crazy ways
um basically what happened is the very
first time we were all together um
the first the first day that we were all
together we all went out we were at an
officers club uh in nevada we were you
know it was this very cultural trip
where we were with the pilots
and um
you know
he took his phone and as you know you
can't do this um put it on the bar top
and forced him to pay or pay for
everyone's drinks in the bar 200 people
which
lou at that point had not spoken to
anybody yet so it was yeah and so
literally lewis had spent this trip we
flew
to nevada together we then drove for an
hour and a half and lou had not spoken
to anybody
not for any reason other than i was just
like he's shy it was like five hours
i was like bob i was like what would bob
do i think bob would what would bob
don't say anything i need that [ __ ] so
then i made and then i paid him back
ultimately ish we were like you have to
pay him back and we're like it took a
little bit of convincing but we did
all our names are all our call signs
were already scripted so when we read
the script they were already there and
joe gave us the opportunity to change
them if we wanted to change them
everyone was like but we earned everyone
wanted to like look at it and try to
figure it out and then we just realized
that like literally our first night
together
we all all of us earned our calls even
glenn yeah i flooded my bathroom that
night because i started the shower and
then passed out on top of the bed and
then
i had to like mop it up at four in the
morning
there was a leak from the ceiling so it
looked like i peed in the trash can
which they didn't um
and then the next day and nobody knew
anything she rose from the ashes wow
which one of the three of you or all
anybody who plays a pilot in this film
do you think is the most like a mini tom
that you could see in like 20 years this
has been it's gonna like have carried on
the mission impossible like franchise
and like who sort of like is the mini-me
of
i feel like everyone
has some
part of him now
um i feel like everyone's taken learned
so much from him and taken those lessons
on to the next projects they do like we
all have such high standards for each
other too like
i expect the most out of these guys and
every time i mean this is ramped up to
maybe come out many times and every time
we sort of have reunions and also we
like hanging out um every time we see
each other like we just get so excited
about the projects that we're working on
and like
we just have such a shorthand about the
level of specificity that we always want
to bring to everything we do
and you know how how carefully we want
to work on the projects and how
passionate we feel about them and i
think that is something that was really
brought out in us especially
by tom i mean he picked people who i
think had that in them who he felt that
from but then also
really encouraged that part of us and
and
taught us how to be on set with that and
showed us a little bit of the magic
of the magic you know behind what's
behind the curtain on his side and how
he makes a film and develops character
and develops story and shoots a film and
you know
stunts why a camera moves the certain
way it does and you start to realize and
again like down to tiny little things
like the way a gunslinger stands and
like that's what these guys are in the
air that's these pilots are in the air
they're gun slingers they're old school
western like you know albie huckleberry
balcomber uh gunslingers you know what i
mean and like even down to little things
like that
and then all of a sudden you realize
like oh that's what makes his film so
great and you want to take that with you
to whatever you do like you can't have
that experience and then just show up at
another on another set and be like ah
whatever you just can't like it's not in
you anymore like you would now know that
you have to give it your all wow your
favorite families in the air force yeah
my grandfather's yeah so did that at all
aid you in sort of jumping into this or
was this a completely like not what you
expected you know so it's funny my dad
was a mechanic so i grew and he he
worked on on on uh jets his his entire
military career so i grew up like if for
any reason i was out of school because i
was always in trouble
i spent a lot of time in his hanger
while he was like working and so i grew
up like
staring at jets all day long and always
wanting to fly but it was also so common
and you know what i mean that it just it
just felt like uh this is just a you
know it's just a part of the everyday
thing
for me it was like the little things of
like coming onto a base every single day
and like you know having to show your id
at the gate and then like you go to a
certain store to shop and then you go
here to watch a movie it was all those
little things for me
that kind of like
really clicked back in and maybe kind of
go back to like these childhood
experiences right we went to a screening
on the on the base of top gun and they
had us like introduce the film and he
was
that was a cool day you like we're
telling all of that yeah i was so
excited as a kid i love the relationship
between both of your characters in this
film because it feels very like as much
as this is about action it feels very
grounded and you're both very unique
characters it's not maybe something you
would expect to see in a top gun film
can you kind of talk about how the two
of you created that
unique bond between
yourselves i mean i feel like there's a
lot of reality and truth to it i mean i
definitely look up look up and looked up
to monica while we were making it and
she was always like
one of the best pilots along with jay
um and and so like it was an honor to be
able to like learn alongside her and she
was able to give me you know tips and
check in on me and it was so there's
some reality and truth to to bob and
phoenix's relationship they they we flew
together the first day we flew was in
um a cessna together so like right off
the bat
i'm like
flying him in the back seat and and vice
versa he flew me as well i remember
being in the back seat and being like he
well wait mo monica
you have the do you have the plan right
now yeah and you're like
i think so
um so we just got like thrown into it
right away um so it was it was easy it's
funny originally in the script our
characters were supposed to have maybe
more contention yeah and they threw that
out pretty quickly because it was like
no we like we like that they like each
other um and it and it works there's
still like the hurdle of
me not maybe listening to you right away
and then and then we start to like
defend each other in other scenes and
it's fun beach scene you had to reshoot
it
you thought you your diet was over and
then you had to reshoot it how painful
was that and come on it was an oil
contest who won who used the most oil
come on was the slipperiest he was the
most glitchy he would have slid off the
stage he was injured himself he was
going down a slip and slide in like two
seconds injured himself that day so
slippery yeah
we we so we shot the scene
we're we've all been working out we're
running we're dieting everyone feels
great everyone looks good uh originally
we shoot that when we get when we go to
shoot the scene there's going to be a
shirts and skins team everyone loses it
everyone's like nah i've been working
way too hard like there's no way i can
be shirts like that's no he should be
shirts yeah absolutely there was only
one shirt actually on that day
one guy almost cried
joe finally folds and he's like fine if
you guys all want to be shirts b r b
skins b skins whatever so we we shoot
the scene
we all feel great it's a beautiful san
diego day it's like the perfect golden
sunset behind us it's absolutely
beautiful on the beach
miles brings like a pack of beers we all
sit around and talk for a little bit
that night we decided to go out to a
spot here in downtown uh we ordered
pizza wings beers everybody's
celebrating like we just had such a
tater tots yeah everybody's celebrating
because this we worked so hard for this
scene
the next day tommy
harper comes to set
and he tells us
we're gonna have to reshoot that again
in like a week or two there was just
some stuff that didn't work in there so
we're gonna have to redo that and
everyone was like i can't do this for
another two weeks please don't make me
go back to this i don't want to do this
it that became a running joke joe would
be like oh yeah we have to we have to do
some reshoots and he's so serious you're
like yeah yeah i know he's good and what
are we shooting oh we just we'll let you
guys know we'll let you guys know what
it is and we shot again post christmas
yeah time yeah post tom cruise cake
and i ate the whole thing myself
wow there's a lot of oil though there
was vaseline there was grape seed oil
there's coconut oil avocado oil glycerin
water
chapstick
sunflower seed oil
this is no joke everyone had everyone
had was a lathered in like at least two
or three of these things
at a time doing push-ups doing push-ups
like running in the water just trying to
get wet so it looks like sweat was
dripping on us it was
avocado oil got me
it's nice you know it's a high heat oil
you know what i mean
those are your pilots
[Music]
you will never forgive yourself
for jennifer's request the greatest
movie experience i have ever had in a
theater it really is what was your
reaction to seeing it more important i
thought i saw it in a big theater
um with my family who were but literally
on the edge of their seats the whole
time my daughter her knees were bouncing
she was
so excited now dude so fun did your kids
had had they watched the original
because they're younger right yeah but i
mean obviously my daughter was born in
2011 but you know yeah um
uh yeah it was it's
it's a spectacle that has so much heart
it's so surprisingly
emotional and moving and you're so
connected to the characters and then
those flying sequences i think if you
love the flying sequences in the
original this is just another level you
know what they accomplished it's
incredible you should be a movie critic
because that was a perfect synopsis for
the film it actually is true and it
ticks all the boxes and i think
uh first of all and i'm sure people are
asking about this i remember in the
original they're like the admiral's
daughter and tom maverick's getting in
trouble for and that's his eventually
penny benjamin and that's your character
um
when that film came out if somebody had
told you that reference you're gonna
play her one day what would you say i
never would have thought that that was
gonna happen
um
yeah i thought it was such a smart thing
such a smart choice
um to make
you know to sort of bring in penny
benjamin and then you can hit the ground
running with the two of them you know
which is great for characters of their
age you know at that point in their life
they have this history together we know
that they have had this history together
um i think it's a you know it's a great
place to start uh their journey in this
film so then because i felt that history
when i watched those scenes how do you
create that what kind of conversations
did you and tom have in crafting that
history and what sort of a backstory did
you create for her aside from the
reference there's a lot of time that you
had to fill in for yourself yeah we
talked about you know the fact that they
had sort of cycled through each other's
lives at various points and um
i thought a lot about you know why they
were good for each other why they kept
doing that you know and i think that you
can feel that in the way she handles
that unresolved business when he walks
into the bar you know she has so much
humor
and playfulness but you can feel her
affection for him for him and her
kindness and um
you know she's an independent woman she
adores him but she's going to set her
own boundaries and she has her own
adventures that she's going on you know
she's every every bit the adventurer
that he is um yeah so they're they're a
good match for one another i think did
you sort of create something for
yourself because watching it i'm like
when you said a few things so like you
weren't letting him in fully in the
first scene as a female i was like oh
yeah there's been moments where he's
really really hurt her and it is kind of
referenced in the film but yeah you
create those little scenarios for
yourself yeah create those it's always
fun to do that and create you know the
writers did an amazing job i think with
the script um
but it's always you know as an actor
make it's one of the things that i love
you know sort of filling in the moments
between and creating that back story and
um making it as detailed as possible
makes everything more specific it does
you know well that came across in the
fact that you are this bar owner the bar
scenes are so iconic in this film and it
continues to be iconic and
or in the last film and in this film it
is just as iconic i really felt your
ownership of that bar i felt that you
had lived in that space
that you would spend some time there
this was your bar
but on the day what does that look like
like was it a set was it an actual bar
they built that bar for the film uh they
built it on the beach they did an
incredible job with it
um and
people loved it so much i think people
in the local community were petitioning
to have it stay at the end of the film i
don't know where that landed i'm pretty
sure it's not there anymore but um
yeah they did an incredible job what did
you do for yourself to make it feel like
that was yours did i spend a lot of time
practicing that tap
you know pouring that beer spent a lot
of time practicing pouring that beer yep
and yeah and i think that's a big
giveaway you know first first beer i
tried to pour from the tap it was like
it was not pretty that was not that was
not film worthy it really pays off i
think when you when you and and i know
that's the way tom works i want to talk
about
again as a female the romantic scenes
what i love about it is that he
in the scenes that i've seen he doesn't
do a lot of love scenes or romantic
scenes
he seems like an old school romantic
nothing salacious it was really
connected
how were those scenes for you in in
filming like what sort of um
atmosphere did you create within you
know as a couple
yeah i felt like i i it's not
exploitative it's not like graphic it's
just more about their connection and
you know
that sort of um
you know the emotion behind their coming
together i think uh more than anything
so
uh i i love the way they did it i was
great you know it was a very different
scene in the original i don't know if
you remember that blue
the blue scene the backlit blue scene
we talked about the fact that we were
not going there this is going to be a
different kind of a different kind of
moment
um more about their you know their
emotional connection and i love it i
love that you have the scene of them
afterwards lito sort of laying in bed
and talking and talking about their
lives and you understand their
friendship and
um and again you know their history
their long history together so i know
that tom took you open a plane you have
a fear of flying
and i'm wondering i didn't admit that to
him i did not reveal that to him he said
he talked about the scene and i just
said that sounds great tom
as you know
as you do because he's just so cool and
you know you try to be like a little bit
cool and i mean who's cool next to tom
cruise
i don't know so when you face your fear
does it lessen the fear like are you
going up again are you like no no no
well i always i never stopped flying i
did go through a period where i it
definitely challenged me um i found it
quite stressful
but i worked on it and i had actually
conveniently decided like i was gonna
take it on before this movie came up so
this was more like the ultimate test of
my work
confronting that fear i did okay
after a couple hours i was ready to land
but i did okay but i honestly i think
that
if it weren't tom flying the plane i'm
not sure
how it would have been
you know i just have so much faith in
him he's so
capable at just about everything that
i've seen him do and from like not
planes trains and automobiles but you
also have your own boat in this and then
he takes you on a motorcycle so and i
have a really cool car
and you have a really cool and he has a
really cool car so how did you sort of
craft the boating scenes did you sort of
know i took i took lessons i took a lot
of lessons um
to try and make it look like i knew what
i was doing i mean that was a lot of
boat to sail um so i definitely had some
help uh and there was a lot of wind and
waves and we shot it up in san francisco
so i had assistance for sure um
but i did take a lot of lessons i was
taking i live in new york city so uh in
brooklyn actually and and um so i was
sailing out of the marina there in new
york harbor which is its own kind of
treacherous i know because i used to
live in new york yeah yeah um and last
question um i don't know how old i know
you're a working actress when the
original came out what was your
connection and probably people are
asking this what was your connection to
the originality did you have to sort of
have you seen it a million times did you
sort of have it i've seen it many times
yeah did you revisit it before sort of
diving i did yeah i revisited it and um
washed it with the kids and watched it
again recently and
um
yeah i had seen it i had seen it several
times and how has it changed for you now
that you've that you've been in this
film when you go back to it now wow it's
really fun it's really fun going back to
it and kind of trying to let it sink in
that i'm part of the sequel because i i
think when you
don't think about it in that way when i
was doing it i approached it as you know
you think about the work and the
character and you know
um
so i don't think of it in the
in that larger sense of context you know
i was so involved in what we were doing
and what we were trying to accomplish
that i wasn't sort of looking at it from
that perspective
so
it's kind of fun and you're like yeah
you were here at the request of admiral
kazansky aka iceman he seems to think
that you have something left to offer
the navy
what that is i can't imagine
just want to manage expectations
first of all the reactions to this film
have been so off the charts i haven't
heard a single like bad note what is
your reaction to the reaction to the
film um
i mean it's obviously it's a it's a
wonderful uh experience to be involved
with something that that is that is well
liked i've had it a few times in my
career and it's certainly better than
the the the opposite reaction um but we
were very proud of the film you know we
i'd seen the movie for the first time in
2020
uh in deep pandemic we saw just the cast
and i and and we were sat you know 15
feet apart with mass on and it was a
very different experience than i think
people are going to have going to the
theaters now which is uh very different
but we knew we had something special and
we knew we knew it when we were making
it i mean this is a continuation of a
story that's 30 years in the making and
and there aren't many things like that
and there aren't many things like that
with a movie star like this
there's there's very few guys that get
to go above the title
and he's he's at the top of the list
he's like gazing into his eyes right now
i'm mesmerizing even so it's easy to do
it's easy to get lost well let's talk
about those scenes that you have because
what i loved about it uh your character
is not he could have easily been this
like over the top one note bad guy and
he's not and the two of you had such an
intense great dynamic but there was
levity there were moments of humor i
want to know just because i want to peek
behind the curtain of the wizard of oz
does he work differently than other
actors when you're doing that kind of a
dramatic scene i know he's very in
control no tom is you know thomas is a
very giving very receptive
human being yeah and and as an actor
he's the same way and he's his
enthusiasm is absolutely infectious and
he obviously cares so deeply about this
story and this character and this world
and it was a tremendous honor to be
invited into that world for sure
um but also it was it was fun you know
part of the how you described the levity
of it was that it was
i think my character understood that yes
he has to enforce the rules and yes he
is responsible for
the hundreds of millions and billions of
dollars of equipment and misses and mats
but but also lives but also he does
understand that what maverick brings to
the table is
undefinable in some ways and so he has
to kind of lean into that as well and uh
these are like real life lessons
sometimes you got to put your chips on
the guy that you're not 100 sure about
but you just have a gut about and that's
that's the story of maverick for sure i
want to know more about cyclone i feel
like you sort of opened pandora's box i
want to know if how much backstory did
you create for your character because i
feel like he has secrets he has a life
that on paper you think it would be one
thing but actually it's something
totally different well stay tuned for
2024's top gun cycle
uh i you know i i had a lot you know
part of it was
was playing a guy that is in charge of a
lot of very
um
expensive and and and important things
not only just from a monetary monetary
standpoint but uh part of it was was
when people's lives are in danger and
meeting guys that that either are
captains of aircraft carriers or run air
bases that are basically tasked with
putting people's lives at stake um
that's a that's a real
you know that'll keep you up at night
for sure
and so i think cyclone is dealing with a
lot of those things as well and uh you
know obviously it's
also it's you know looking
sharp and looking tan but is he blown
off steam i feel like he's also there's
got to be a balance right like for sure
you know we just didn't get to see those
things i feel like he's in the bar scene
somewhere in the back
way back he waits for he waits for
everybody so obviously you saw the
original i'm sure you had a you were a
teenager when the movie came out
um
when you go now that you've done this
film
how does it change the way you look at
the original it's funny you know the
original
is is very much of the 80s um and tony
scott
an amazing director rest in peace he's a
he did such a he made they made such a
great movie jerry bruckheimer don
simpson and everybody involved with that
production it was it was and deserves to
be held in the esteem that it that it is
and for many people it was like that
meant hollywood for the longest time and
it inspired a generation of naval
aviators people joined the navy because
of that movie
um and so yes it does live in this kind
of uh place in our hearts for sure and
like i said i think the movie strikes
such a great balance of um nostalgia for
the original and then the continuation
of the story is is just a real um
is a real pleasure on on a couple
different levels did you have aviation
envy were you at all jealous that you
didn't pull g's and get no
you were totally fine with that the
simple answer is no i you know there was
a little bit sure it would have been a
fun experience to do that but i was so
glad i did not have to do you know the
months and months and months of training
that those guys had to do um and i'm so
pleased for for
for all of them actually because because
the the proof is in the pudding and you
and you really do see on screen
broadcast at 50 feet high how their
dedication to that craft it was amazing
so you have the rare privilege of you've
met mom cruise not tom cruise
mom cruz how did that meeting go and was
that the first time you met tom um
i i guess that might have been the first
time that i met tom that was years and
years ago it was at jimmy kimmel's house
he had a bunch of people over to watch
football on a sunday and someone said
you know tom cruise is coming over and
we're like yeah right that's not going
to happen and those are grown men like
we're all you know sitting around
watching football you know and eating
food
and [ __ ] and uh
knock on the door and who walks in but
tom cruise with his mom and we
literally were all just like
gobsmacked like
this is how is this happening and hey
guys you watching football
yeah what's up tom cruise how you doing
uh so yeah that was years and years ago
but uh i had since met tom on a few
other occasions and uh he is a very
friendly and approachable guy it's uh
it's
it's a rare thing for a movie star that
has been a movie star for going on four
decades
to be that
regular and approachable and how's mom
and his mom's lovely she's just chill
and just like this
um
i mean you're talking i mean it's
amazing that you're talking about tomlin
because you've had such an incredible
you are having an incredible career with
so many memorable like you said
memorable roles great roles where does
sort of this fit into the pantheon in
terms of your experience as an actor i
mean it's right up there i it's i i've
i'll say i've truly never been involved
with something like this at this level
i've done my favorite movies and i've
been on television shows and i've had my
fair share of accolades and and whatnot
but this is a very different
experience even just
even just the like kind of uh experience
of doing the press for it i knew that
this was going to be
you know from san diego we have the
premiere here then we go to mexico city
then we go back to la then we go to
london and can and london and new york
and and that's just me the rest of the
team goes around the world and it's it's
a very different
level and it's a very exciting level um
and i'm just thrilled to be a part of it
i'm trying to keep my eyes and ears open
and really take it all in i feel like a
lot of the roles and none of the roles
you've chosen have been similar but they
always have an edge like whether it's
bridesmaids he had an edge we'll just
say that
whether it's mad men whether it's this
are these roles attracted to you are you
attracted to these types of roles
because when i used to do a little bit
of acting and i got so ti i was cast for
things that are opposite to who i am do
you feel that way uh sometimes i think i
i'm i'm
tremendously uh fortunate in my career
and i i will be the first one to say it
but i'm also uh excited to do the things
that i get to do and uh
yeah you know the finding the the layers
of the character is is the is the most
fun uh
part of
the of the process so i'm glad i get to
keep doing it
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
and we're off
um both of you really ground the film
literally you're both on the ground but
also you sort of have the dramatic some
of the most more dramatic scenes but
also like a tinge of humor um first of
all you kind of open the film in a sense
like that was the scene where i was like
okay
i don't know how this movie's gonna be
and that set the tone did you kind of
where in the filming process did you
shoot that scene
was it towards the beginning because i
could feel the tension you know uh
and this is not even trying to sound
facetious
uh i don't remember it's all the blurry
it was so much fun
i just know i woke i woke up every day
ready for a new adventure but i will say
um every day and i'm sure you would
agree every day we go to set it feels
like your first day because there's so
much excitement and anticipation you
know luckily we have tom who really you
know works hard to make us feel um as
appreciated as and and he's very
thoughtful you know about saying hey
we're really all in this together we all
need to shine we all need to do well but
that scene was uh particularly exciting
to shoot i got to work with ed harris
come on uh you know and it just allowed
us to really you know we knew it was
early in the movie and we were really
eager to set an exciting tone for the
film and i think we did it really did
because that tension and you're kind of
like does maverick still have it all
these years later and you really and you
really felt it your character
um it's sort of on the other side of the
team you're you're you know you're both
on different sides of the team you work
more for john hamm's character with john
john hamm's character can you talk about
building that dynamic with both john and
with tom on set i want to know all the
magic like we hear how magical tom is
but i want i want details
well i had to kind of dance a fight in
line between cyclone john hamm and
maverick and i kind of helped maverick
along his path while still
keeping my duties in order and i am an
admiral so there's certain a certain
path i have to follow but i try to help
him as much as i can so i feel like i'm
maverick's behavior interpreter so he
does wild and crazy stuff and i bring it
down and put it in english so that
cyclone can understand it and i'm trying
to bring them together
so that maverick can complete the
mission that i know he's capable of
completing but
cyclone is having his issues with it
well that's what i like about the film
too if there's nobody that's purely bad
and nobody like it's not cliche yeah in
any way i feel like this was a perfect
script
like 36 years in the making and worth it
or 34 however many it was but for you as
actors you're both been acting a long
time can you talk about
as a viewer this sets itself apart from
anything i've seen but as an actor how
does it set itself apart from anything
you've acted in there's only going to be
one sequel to top gun for the rest of
time now there may you know who knows
what the future will hold but in terms
of that original i mean what i mean
specifically is
in terms of the movie that follows that
original there could only be one and so
to get the chance to be a part of that i
had to pinch myself i thought when i got
the phone call somebody was pranking me
i said you know what you need to hang up
this phone right now this is not a nice
thing to do to somebody to hang out and
you know oh no this is real okay good
all right i was just testing you i'm
kidding
guys come on
just just joshing um but you know i
think we
were aware uh of the weight that the
movie had i mean the original top gun is
so interwoven in the fabric of american
life i mean it's like up there with
baseball and apple pie and i think the
fact that it took many decades for the
sequel to come is a testament to the
filmmakers and tom's insistence that
they do something special and they do
something that it's in itself in itself
original you know we're not just
remaking the original movie this is a
whole new movie and i think audiences
are gonna be floored yeah um for you and
then you're the only room that i'm going
to ask to sing because you'll probably
get it asked a lot and both are old
enough to remember the original i loved
the original i have such a
deep connection with it what was your
connection with the original film did
you have to sort of go back or you like
i've seen this a million times i don't
need to see this again i know where
we're at
it was a little bit of both because i
have seen it a million times and it's
one of those things you stop on whenever
you're passing it on tv
but i still have to take like a
concentrated look at it and then try to
think of the things that are going to
connect that movie with our movie so um
and then watching it you get more and
more excited because the more i'm
watching the original top gun i keep
thinking
i'm going to be in the next one
[Laughter]
i used to sit in the theater and just
chew popcorn and think man i'd love to
be in a movie like that it's like i'm
gonna be in a movie like that you know
uh so that feeling overwhelms you for a
while and then you get to work and you
meet tom and he's
all energy he's right there looking you
in the eye and he greets everybody every
morning with good morning good morning
he's happy to be there every day so you
get
caught up in the energy and the
enthusiasm of the film and then you
forget about feeling like pressure or
anything like that because now you're
right
and i don't know when you saw it but my
theater exploded and called for the film
to be played again after it ended
everybody's like again again we'll sit
through it again
and i'm sure you've seen the reaction
what is your reaction to the reactions
that are out there and what was your
reaction watching the film for the first
time you know i feel like you know tom
cruise uh he knows how to make a good
movie um and i think part of that is is
even you know working with him you know
he's constantly talking about audience
he's aware that people work hard and
they spend their harder money to come
watch us on screen how do we reward that
how do we make sure that when people
show up that we give them what they
deserve and that's really important to
him i almost sometimes
my brain think of it as like designing
the perfect roller coaster right got to
have the right dips and turns at the
right place and so to see the audience
reaction
to see that borne out to see the passion
that the filmmakers had to make this
movie i was so happy
there's a couple of amazing mantras in
this film one of them is like don't
think just do
do either of you have a mantra in life
as an actor
my mantra would be
tell the truth and all will be well
as an actor my mantra is
read the script before you go to set
make sure you got your lines done one of
those days before you show up to shoot
just find the time
take a read look at what happens look at
the words you're working on you finish
mission impossible
uh seven yes yes i've finished my work
on seven what is the difference like how
is the difference working on that film
versus top gun
tom being the common thread but what is
sort of a different how is it the vibe
different
well the way that uh mission impossible
is being made is a little more um
free-flowing
from day to day and decisions are being
made
kind of with uh moving parts kind of all
going and you kind of make decisions
based on what's in front of you whereas
i feel like top gun had more of a plan
and things have to be separated like the
flying and the training for the flying
and then the ground crew so
um i guess top gun's a little more
structured right now then okay than my
experience of mission impossible seven
both uh totally energetic both
aimed to please and exhilarate the
audience though that's the common thread
now did i read that tom was a fan of
south south side let me tell you about
tom
cruise brief with this because people
don't understand you know there's a
certain thing called hollywood speak and
then hollywood speaks somebody goes like
hey i love you and that just means
nothing it doesn't mean anything uh you
know you hear it all the time you hear
people read scripts so we're on set tom
and i talked a lot about chicago he shot
movies there and i mentioned that i was
doing a show he said oh i want to see it
i want to see it i was like okay he's so
busy he doesn't want to actually see it
no no he emailed me he's like yo what's
up he said you were going to send me the
show i was like oh yeah yeah dude tom
cruise let me send it to you send it to
him and a couple months later we were in
the writer room
i get a phone call from tom he has
watched the whole season he is pitching
me the jokes he liked he's talking about
the characters he loved he said the
writing is so crisp and i said tom you
know i'm in the writing room right now
he's like can i talk to the writers so
then of course i have the great pleasure
in my life of being able to go hey guys
you guys tom cruise wants to talk to you
putting him on speakerphone no way
just gushing
their faces they were over the moon but
it's so nice you know in a world where
folks kind of just say things to say
them to actually have someone who's
genuine and who really means it and tom
is that guy well last question for both
of you your real life call sign
if you had a call sign in life what
would it be
miami
miami oh i feel you on that you got a
little miami vice happening right
mine would
[Laughter]
mine would be uh
wheat berry
wheat berry why i like that what's that
about say bake
i'm a sourdough bread baker
you said that like an admiral or a
general i bake
unseen
no turning back now
come on
[Music]
having any fun
yet i'm sure you've seen some of the
reactions some people have seen it
already what is your reaction to reading
the response the overwhelmingly positive
response to this film well you know i i
was at cinemacon last week so i got to
sit with 3 000 people uh and experience
it for the first time with an audience
finished and uh it was just i was
relieved you know i was nervous um i was
just happy to see you know a lot of the
humor landed because that's the kind of
stuff that you kind of forget as you're
watching the movie and working on it
over and over but to see all those beats
land to see
you know people really respond to what
tom did in this movie and the
performance he brings to it um
you know he really gets a chance to act
in this film which is really exciting
and uh
so i'm just i'm just so proud of the
whole cast and everyone that worked on
it well that's what's so amazing about
it is it hits drama comedy action
there's so much woven into one i don't
know if you i was at cinemacon if you
heard us in the balcony calling for it
to be played again after it ended no but
that was the reaction people wanted to
see it again oh good
right the way i hope people do yeah i
think they will i think there's going to
be a lot of repeat viewings um
i heard you say that you wanted to make
a film when you're approaching something
as huge as top gun that has such a
legacy
that really it came down to making
something for yourself that you love and
that you would want to see can you sort
of talk about that a little bit is that
sort of what grounded you even in a film
about aviation and grounded you as a
director and tackling this thing no i
think as a director you have to you have
to make it for yourself because if you
try to please everyone else you'll get
pulled in a thousand different
directions so for me
you know it was going back to the
feeling i had as a 12 year old kid
seeing it in you know may 1986 on the
big screen and
capturing that feeling uh again
obviously having tom and jerry
bruckheimer next to me while making it
was incredible because they were you
know part of the original and
so yeah you have to make it for yourself
and then hope that it connects you know
when it comes out it definitely connects
um
you work with tom and oblivion what is
it like approaching material
that's new versus sacred ground well
this is you know this is one of the
jewels if not the biggest jewel in his
crown right i mean this is top gun and
uh from the very beginning tom said to
me he's like
this is hitting a bullet with a bullet
like
this is going to be this is going to be
tough this is going to be hard two
miracles two hands gonna take two
miracles yeah
uh and uh so every day you know we just
pushed ourselves to make sure that we
were telling the best version we
possibly could and um
you know uh
it was it was it was an adventure every
day i'm sure for you as a director too
when you're working with tom who knows
his material so well he knows what he
wants he's a visionary himself can you
give me a little
just a little taste of behind the scenes
what that partnership and that
collaboration is like as he as inspiring
as it seems he would be yeah he you know
wakes up thinking about the film you
know and goes to sleep probably dreams
about it like he's just in it and it's
inspiring to me it's inspiring to
everyone on the crew
um you know it was it's a partnership
when you're working with him i mean look
at the film look at what he's doing you
know he's he's not only interested in
what his character is doing but he's
interested in all facets of the
filmmaking process um
he's made movies for 35 years you know
and worked with
all of my heroes in terms of directors
so um
i just i just learned a tremendous
amount for him i hate to ask but what is
what was one thing he taught you that
you didn't know
oh my gosh i mean it's so many things uh
you know
what tom talks about is communicating
with the audience and sometimes the
thing that you want a scene to
communicate even though you see it
sometimes the audience doesn't get it so
it's really important i think what he
really taught me was in those test
previews really listening to what the
audience is saying and make sure they're
seeing the same thing you are in a scene
and and learning how to use those
previews to to hone the movie i think
was a really good lesson so as a
director i want to talk about the rialto
camera is that what it was called yeah
the shooting in 6k having six cameras in
and around the planes
um and these cameras are were created
specifically for this film this is the
first time they were used they're made
by sony it's called the sony venice and
the rialto is the version that splits
into two pieces so it makes it kind of
half size
and that's the camera that allowed us to
get six in the cockpit
so it took us about 15 months working
with the navy to figure out how to do it
and to get clearance to do it because
they you know if the pilot needs to
eject or there's an emergency the
cameras can't interfere with any of the
systems um so it was a huge engineering
exercise but um you know when you see
what we were able to capture you just
can't fake that so 16 12 to 16 hour days
for 30 to 45 seconds of footage what
thing one thing i found was astounding
was how you connected
story to action i can't imagine how
difficult that was to have all that
footage
are you going to do anything with that
any of that extra footage will we see
extended cuts of any scenes or
additional scenes you might see some
additional scenes um there would there
isn't a lot on the cutting room floor in
terms of scenes
definitely the behind the scenes videos
that we've created to tell how we made
the film are pretty epic i think there's
six or seven like half hour pieces we've
put together that'll be available
um so there'll be plenty of material for
people to see how we made it any chance
of a trilogy have you thought oh my god
is it possible i know i know you just
put this to bed but you know we have to
ask because we want more now i know
would you be open to it 35 years to make
this one you know let's see in 35 years
i'll be in my you know 80s uh you know
we'll see i don't think we can wait that
long but would you be open to it
you know if we could find the right
story i mean again it's like it took
five years just to get this one out it's
hard to imagine
diving in right away but you know it's
all about the story um were you there i
heard ridley scott
rather of the late tony scott watch the
film um were you there with him no jerry
jerry you know
jerry and tony were very very close made
a lot of movies together so jerry and
ridley uh have history they watched it
together uh and jerry called me right
after and said really loved it and that
just that meant a lot and i'm gonna end
with a bang any of the explosions
practical or were they cg there are
there are some practical explosions in
the movie absolutely wow yeah